الانتصار ، شكراً جزيلاً لك ما زلت غاضبًا
بشأن
مقارنة الرئيس دونالد ترامب
بيننا وبين بلد من العالم الثالث
حيث بدا وكأنه يعترف بأن
جهوده القانونية لتغيير النتائج
لم تذهب إلى أي مكان الآن ، وكان هذا مثل
أمة من العالم الثالث
وأعتقد أن  تم رفع القضية
والآن نكتشف ما يمكننا القيام به حيال ذلك
ولكن القضية لم يتم ترشيحها
وقد خسر حلفاؤه أو سحبوا
ما لا يقل عن 40 قضية قضائية منذ الانتخابات
الآن تقول المصادر لـ CNN أنه بين تلك
الخسائر في المحكمة
بعض سريع  مع اقتراب المواعيد النهائية وإدخال
محاميه الأعلى إلى المستشفى بسبب
فيروس كورونا
، قد تنتهي جهود الرئيس القانونية
قريبًا
بشكل جيد وأعتقد أن القضية قد تم رفعها
بالفعل إذا نظرت إلى صناديق الاقتراع ،
كانت هناك صفحتان أخريان
لجهود الرئيس ألقى القضاة الفيدراليون في
ميشيغان المحاولة الأخيرة
لقلب النتيجة هناك
استدعاء دعوى ترامب حليف سيدني باول
لا تقتبس سوى التكهنات
والتخمين وحالة جورجيا
التراجع  إذا كانت نتائجه بعد عد
الأصوات الرئاسية للمرة الثالثة
وتأكيد فوز جو بايدن مرة أخرى
على الرغم مما ادعى الرئيس ترامب
خلال مسيرة حاشدة هناك ليلة السبت ،
فأنت تعلم أننا فزنا بجورجيا فقط حتى تفهم
أنه منح ميدالية الحرية
للمصارعة الأسطورة دان
جابل  حاول ترامب مقارنة
سجلاتهم وادعى خطأً أنه فاز في
انتخابين رئاسيين جيدًا كما تعلم
في السياسة ،
فزت في اثنتين ، لذا فأنا
2-0 وهذا جيد جدًا ولكننا سنرى
كيف اتضح أن
ترامب قدم أيضًا تحديثًا بشأن  حالة
محاميه الشخصي رودي جولياني
بعد قبوله البالغ من العمر 76 عامًا في
المركز الطبي لجامعة جورجتاون
مصابًا
بفيروس كورونا ، لقد
تحدثت إليه للتو أنه يعمل بشكل جيد للغاية
ولم يكن جولياني يتجول
في البلاد لدفع
مزاعم ترامب التي لا أساس لها بشأن
في الانتخابات
وغالبًا ما كان يستقبل الناس
بمصافحة وبدون قناع بينما
يرفض ترامب الاعتراف بفوز بايدن أو
حتى الاتصال به.  علم الرئيس القادم سي إن إن
أنه يخطط بالفعل
لخطواته التالية
ويتكهن بعض الموظفين الآن بأنه
قد لا يعود إلى البيت الأبيض بعد
ذهابه إلى فلوريدا لقضاء عطلة عيد الميلاد على
الرغم من عدم اتخاذ قرارات نهائية